is math invented or discovered so when
you say assembly invented
or whatever uh uh you you mean this
simply is a mathematical theory but
sorry
right we argue exactly are we arguing
that that's what it sounds like are we
discovering
no well yes and no i would say
you called mathematics a language
i would say developing like i'm pretty
sure that um
there there are some very common seeds
of mathematics in the universe right
but actually not the mathematics that we
are
finding now
is not discovered it's invented
and but even though i think those two
terms are very triggering and i don't
think they're necessarily useful because
i think that what people do the
mathematicians that say oh mathematics
was discovered
because they live in a universe where
there is no time and it just all exists
but what i'm saying is and i think in
the same way you can create let's say
i'm going to go and create and
make a piece of art
did i make that piece of art or did i
escape discover it
like inventing the airplane did i invent
the aeroplane let's stick with the
airplane the airplane is a good one i
let's say i'm i did i discovered the
airplane well in a way the universe
discovered the aeroplanes it just
chucked a load of atoms together a load
of random human beings one day stuff and
they we we discovered the aeroplane in
the space of possibilities but here's
the thing when the space of
possibilities is so
vast
infinite almost
and you're able to actualize one of
those in an object and you are inventing
it so in mathematics because there are
infinite number of theorems the fact
you're actually pulling there's no
difference between
inventing a mathematical structure and
inventing the airplane they're the same
thing but that doesn't mean that now the
airplane exists in the universe it's
something weird about the universe that
you know so i think that the more this
is the thing that you probably the more
memory
required for the object the more
invented it is so when a mathematical
theorem has a
hazard needs more bytes to store it the
more invented it is and the less bites
the more discovered is but everything
then is invented it's just more or less
invented absolutely okay
has to generate everything as it goes
yeah
and it wasn't there in the beginning and
the way we're thinking it
when you're thinking about the
difference between an event and
discovered is because we're throwing
away all the memory yeah so if you start
to think in terms of causality and time
then those things become the same
everything is invented
and the idea is to make everything
intrinsic to the universe so i think one
of the features of assembly theory is we
don't want to have external observers
there's been this long tradition in
physics of trying to describe the
universe from the outside and not the
inside
and
the universe has to generate everything
itself if you do it from the inside
assembly theory describes how the
universe builds itself
you